So I'm pretty happy because yesterday we had a nice winter storm and you can
see that it's pretty white outside. It's also pretty sunny. It's actually
brighter on a winter day than it is on a summer day for us here in Canada because
the the sun reflects off the snow. There's a couple things that I need to do
today and I'll teach you some English along the way. One is I need to clean
my driveway out. I'm actually going to blow the driveway out with the snow
blower and I'm going to do a little bit of sledding with the kids. It's actually
it's actually hard to walk through this snow right now. I don't know if you can
see. We're a little bit snowed in today. When you're snowed in it means that there's
so much snow that we can't get our vehicles out. It is a really nice day
though. It's cold. It's minus 15. You don't want to be out here too long without
bundling up. So you can see I have my winter hat on which we call a tuc in
Canada. I got my winter gloves. Got my winter boots. Got my winter boots on my
feet and I got lots of layers on so I'm nice and bundled up to stay warm. So the
accumulation that's the amount of snow that came down. They said was going to
be 10 to 25 centimeters. I think here we got maybe about 10 centimeters. So when
it's this cold outside you want to make sure that you don't get frostbite. Frost
bite is when your skin actually freezes. When it's minus 15 you can safely be
outside for quite a while an hour or two but you do want to make sure that
you're covered up as much as possible when you're out in cold weather. We'll go
and see if we can get the big tractor started now. If I lived in the city I
would have to clean my driveway with a shovel or a small snowblower. Not as fun.
For me it's a lot more fun to clean it with the tractor. So it's so cold that in
order to start the tractor we have to have it plugged in. We don't plug our
cars in in the winter in this part of Canada but there are parts of Canada
where it's so cold that you have to plug your vehicles in at night just to
keep them warm. There's a small heater inside. So we do this with things like
tractors around here. I'm always glad when things start in the winter when it gets
this cold. So this machine here on the back of my tractor is a snowblower. What
it does is it'll bring the snow in here and it'll shoot it out through that
piece up there. I'll give you a little video of it working. That's how you move
a lot of snow really really fast. So probably won't be very easy to see. It's
very safe to drive a tractor at the same time as running a snowblower. So
driveways all nice and cleaned out. We'll be able to get the vehicles out now when
we need to go to work. I'm not sure if you can see out there but we have what are
called snow drifts. So snow in the winter will get picked up by the wind
after it's on the ground and it will start to drift. It'll start to build
little snow drifts in different areas. Drifting can be a little annoying because
after you've cleaned the driveway, after you've shoveled or blown the driveway
out, the wind can fill it back in again. So that's never fun because then you
have to go and clean the driveway again. I'll probably have to clean the driveway
again a bit later. So when it's cold and windy at the same time, we have
something that's called the wind chill factor. And the wind chill factor is it'll
feel colder than it actually is. So right now it's minus 15. That's the actual
temperature. But with the wind chill, it feels like minus 20. So the real
temperature is minus 15 degrees Celsius. But with the wind chill factor, it
actually feels five degrees colder. And it's cold out here. It's so cold, in
fact, that my camera only works for about five minutes before it says that
it's too cold. And then it shuts down on me. So I've been outside like four
times now to make this video. So we're going to head behind the house right
now, we have a hill. And the hill has a nice covering of snow on it. And the
kids are back there sledding. They have their sleds out there. Sliding is when
you get a sled and you go down a hill, you slide down the hill on the sled or
toboggan. We also sometimes use toboggan's in Canada, but it's a lot of fun. So
let's let's go check it out. Yeah, let's look at the camera. Hi, Bob, the
Canadian here. Winter is finally here. We're outside doing some sledding, some
tobogganing. I think I'm going to go down the hill now. Okay, you go first. Wish me
luck. Okay, try not to hit the camera on my way down. Oh, that hurt a little bit.
Well, hey, Bob, the Canadian here. Learn English with Bob the Canadian. Thanks for
helping me clean my driveway. And for taking a ride down the hill on a sled.
Don't forget to click the subscribe button below and give me a thumbs up if
this video helped you learn some English. And I'll see you next week in the next
video. I'm just super happy that we got some snow. I think most Canadians like
snow. Not all of us, but most of us. Anyways, have a great day.